en este vídeo vamos a estudiar series
geométricas y para entenderlo voy a
construir una tabla para comprender cómo
podría crecer nuestro dinero si
depositamos digamos mil pesos al año en
una cuenta bancaria digamos que este es
el año y vamos a pensar cuánto tenemos
al comienzo del año y luego estos son
los pesos en nuestra cuenta digamos que
el banco siempre está dispuesto a darnos
el 5% anual lo cual es bastante bueno es
muy difícil encontrar una cuenta
bancaria que realmente de un crecimiento
del 5% anual eso significa que si
depositas 100 pesos al final de un año o
exactamente un año más tarde tendrás 105
pesos si depositas mil pesos un año más
tarde tendrás mil 50 tendrás un 5% más
entonces digamos que queremos depositar
mil pesos por año y quiero saber cuál
será mi saldo al comienzo del primer año
al principio del segundo año al
principio del tercer año y luego trata
de encontrar una expresión general para
el comienzo del año n
entonces el primer año justo al inicio
del año deposite mil pesos en la cuenta
eso es bastante sencillo pero entonces
qué pasa en el segundo año voy a
depositar mil pesos pero luego esos mil
pesos originales habrán crecido de modo
que voy a depositar mil pesos y luego
los mil pesos originales que deposite al
comienzo del primer año ahora han
crecido un 5% crecer en un 5% es lo
mismo que multiplicar por 1.05 así que
esto va a ser más mil pesos por 1.05
bastante sencillo ahora qué pasa con el
comienzo del tercer año cuánto tendría
en la cuenta bancaria si hiciera ese
primer depósito en el tercer año pausa
este vídeo y trata de resolverlo bueno
al igual que al comienzo del segundo año
y el comienzo del primer año vamos a
hacer un depósito de mil pesos pero
ahora el dinero del segundo año ha
crecido en un 5% por lo que ahora será
de mil pesos por 1.05 y luego ese dinero
que originalmente depositamos
el primer año y que era mil por 1.05 en
el segundo año crecerá en otros 5 por
ciento y así esto va a ser más mil por
1.05 x 1.05 estamos creciendo en otro 5%
bueno podríamos reescribir esta parte
que tenemos aquí como 1.05 al cuadrado
entonces puedes ver un patrón general de
lo que está sucediendo aquí pausa el
vídeo nuevamente y trata de escribir una
expresión general vas a tener que poner
estos puntos ves y puedes escribir una
expresión general para el año n bueno
para el año n vas a ganar esos mil pesos
originales al comienzo del año n y luego
tendrás mil pesos por 1.05 por esos mil
pesos que depositas al principio del año
n 1 y luego esto continuará hasta llegar
a más mil pesos por 1.05 a la potencia
del número de años que has estado
depositando entonces podrías hacer estos
mil pesos como los que depositas en el
1er
y luego cuántos años se han acumulado
bueno cuando pasas de 1 a 2 has
acumulado un año cuando pasas de 1 a 3
has acumulado 2 años de modo que cuando
estamos hablando al comienzo del año n
elevas al exponente que es 1 - ese año
así esto va a ser elevado a la potencia
n
1 lo que acabamos de hacer aquí es que
construimos cada uno de estos cuando
decimos cuánto dinero tenemos en nuestra
cuenta bancaria al comienzo del tercer
año o cuánto tenemos en nuestra cuenta
bancaria al comienzo del año n
estas son series geométricas y lo
escribiré series geométricas
ahora solo como un pequeño repaso o
puede que no sea un repaso las series
están relacionadas con las sucesiones y
en realidad puedes ver a las series como
sumas de sucesión es una sucesión es una
lista ordenada de números una sucesión
podría ser algo así como digamos que
tenemos una sucesión geométrica en una
sucesión geométrica cada término
sucesivo es el término anterior
multiplicado por un número fijo así que
digamos que comenzamos con dos y cada
vez multiplicamos por tres entonces
empezamos en 2 2 por 3 y 6 6 por 3 es 18
18 por 3 54 ésta es una sucesión
geométrica una lista ordenada de números
ahora si queremos pensar en las series
geométricas o la que es análoga a estos
sumaríamos los términos aquí de modo que
esto sería 2 + 6 + 18 54 o incluso
podríamos escribirlo y esto sería
similar a lo que acabamos de hacer con
nuestro pequeño ejemplo de ahorro
esto es dos más dos por tres más dos por
tres al cuadrado más dos por tres a la
tercera potencia y así con las series
geométricas tendrás una suma donde cada
término sucesivo en la expresión es
igual a si los pones todos en orden será
igual al término anterior por una
cantidad fija entonces el segundo
término es igual al primer término por
tres y los estamos sumando en una
sucesión solo los estás mirando es una
lista ordenada por así decirlo pero aquí
está sumando la lista ordenada así que
en este ejemplo acabamos de ver lo que
es una serie geométrica pero también un
famoso ejemplo de su utilidad y esto fue
muy superficial si tuvieras que
profundizar en finanzas o negocios
verías series geométricas por todos
lados